so i've uh finally started to settle in
my new place now oh yeah um yeah we are
20 years later 20 years later you know
um you know hosted uh the housewarming
unfortunately joey couldn't make it
because you were busy with the uh
yeah i will say yeah lovely lasagna yeah
i will say ever since that day so okay
so i don't know if i've told the story
of the world famous lasagna yet which
it's it's not world famous but it's
about to be okay it's now it's about to
be so
um so in japan i don't know why but you
can get a lot of good italian food in
japan but for some reason you just can't
get lasagna like no italian restaurant
in japan for some reason serves lasagna
and the few that they do they definitely
don't serve good lasagna yeah so because
of this i would just like look i've been
living in japan for a year i'm craving
lasagna so what better way to do it then
just learn how to do it yourself absorb
myself [ __ ] literally [ __ ] thanos
i'll [ __ ] do it myself right so about
a year ago i didn't even realize i was a
fan
line that can be attached to any
character i could say anything i could
be like oh my penis is a little lychees
like i remember when thanos said that
i'll do it myself i'll talk myself
so about a year ago i learned how to
cook lasagna and i cook it once right i
i cook it once and it was like it was
like a mediocre lasagna all right and uh
it's a difficult dish right yeah i mean
kind of kind of like lego but with pasta
yeah it's it's like it's cool it's a
it's a pasta cake right it's just it's
just concentrated pasta with meat sauce
that's kind of what it is it's like all
the flavor of pesto bowl right layers
out very precisely right yeah right so
deep doing quarantine uh sometimes we
would you know have have dinner parties
where we we would invite people over or
just people would come over yeah and one
day sydney sydney invites conor over and
and she says oh you can have some of
gant's world famous lasagna and i'm just
like and connor's like what i'm just
like what what do you mean world famous
sydney i've cooked it once
and ever since she said that because she
didn't say it to connor she said it to
me lynn as well and so for like a good
five months people have like people have
built up this idea that i make world
famous lasagna it's a joke it's it's
just a joke jesus out here like doing
just misinformation yeah i just dropped
people out have you had a go on sport
famous lasagna yeah
and and so
and so the first time i actually cook it
for like for like may lin yeah
maitland's the one i want to please the
most of course
that good google room yeah yeah of
course of course because if you can
please mail in with a meal you can do
you know it's good
it's basically it's basically michelin
star at that point it is world famous so
the first time i cook it was at maylin's
house and when you're cooking in a in a
kitchen that you're unfamiliar with with
equipment that you don't know you know
sometimes kitchen you know sometimes you
have an oven and you don't know you like
with japanese ovens especially the ones
that aren't pre-built but the ones that
you buy you they say a temperature but
they don't actually the actual
temperature varies depending on what
oven and what brand you buy right that's
true yeah so i remember first time i
cooked this lasagna was uh for the
public was that mayolin's house
for the public for the world it's so
world
it's so world famous
to cook it and i i was like i was like
[ __ ] sweating because like weeks
before
i come to i come to mainland's house to
cook it bailey was like can't wait for
the world famous lasagna you know what
you know i'm i'ma give you a [ __ ]
google review just you know just to see
if it is actually world famous i'm like
for [ __ ] sake man this this joke has
gone the price so far i have this is
like this is like cooking for gordon
ramsay or something right i feel like
i'm part of like kitchen nightmares or
something right now so i'm cooking i'm
cooking at mailing's house and uh it
takes a while to lasagna right because
it's not it's not like an easy dish you
gotta cook the meat sauce
for difficult you gotta layer it up and
i wasn't familiar with maelyn's oven i
cooked it a bunch of times my own oven
and the first time i cook it in
melinda's oven something that an
experienced chef would say yeah i cook
it in mainland's oven and unfortunately
it was
it wasn't hot enough her oven didn't go
hot enough so i liked it so you had a
you had a crispy lasagna yeah so i
cooked it and a little al dente lasagna
yeah so that ain't al dente that's
crispy what's that what's the crispy one
not elden what is al dente i don't know
is that just satisfying means uh to the
bite right so it's like just right
softness yeah i think yeah italians
please confirm do you say italian words
like just say that it was definitely mia
i cooked my lasagna mamma mia yeah i
mean it wasn't it wasn't fully cooked
but the inside was definitely as gordon
ramsay would say [ __ ] raw
it's hard i mean even if lasagna is like
raw i'm like this is still pretty
[ __ ] cool i don't mind my lasagna a
little crunchy i mean okay connor connor
enjoyed it when when i could not a picky
man with lasagna yeah as long as you
have all the ingredients in yeah yeah i
mean the meat sauce is pretty good but
melin
nothing goes past melissa she takes one
bite and she's like this is raw
this is this is raw and i'm just like
the energy of going around yeah i'm just
like uh
you know my my cooking career is over
after one dish you know this is this is
it i'm gonna i'm gonna be sad i'm gonna
put up my apron now i'm never gonna cook
again i'm just like i got to experience
this toy movie yeah in like real time
and so uh and so that was the last time
i cooked uh lasagna for other people to
taste
actually deterred you yeah yeah until
until
until this housewarming party where
sydney obviously invites you know uh
sydney advice everyone and she sends
people
she sends people this menu as well
things that we were going to cook right
right and i'm just like sydney why would
you do that and without my knowledge she
said she said i would be cooking the
world famous lasagna
literally
yeah i feel like a retired hero or
something you know i'm just like sydney
i've never done that in years i'm past
my prime now i can't do it i can't do it
cindy don't make me do it i'm she's like
gone it's out maelyn's coming you need
to do it right and so i'm so like i'm
i'm like sweating now so
so a few days before the lasagna if a
few days before the housewarming
i have a practice run oh my god
i actually i actually got so nervous
that i'm just like i need to uh i need
to i need to practice i need to like i
need to get my lasagna making skills are
a little rusty i need i need to get back
on the get back on the pedestal see how
it is done again um and so
yeah so i've got some oil in these bones
yeah so i did my lasagna and sydney
loves it but i'm just like i can do
better i i need to do better
i make something let's go further beyond
i make some mental notes before the
before the day about what what about
like the small changes i'm going to make
to the recipe like the small changes i'm
going to make to the preparation and
everything and so the day comes oh it's
like you're going to like a bake-off it
is
this is
a joke like imagine cooking for maelyn
you know but it's like your own i would
never dare to but it's your own personal
recipe you know
like i i think i would actually rather
cook for gordon ramsay at this point um
and so
everyone comes everyone comes and you
know everyone has all the different you
know side dishes we have some meatballs
we have some other things
but the lasagna is the main dish and
like everyone's everyone's having a
merry time i'm [ __ ] sweating not just
because of the heat from the oven but
i'm sweating out of nerves i look very
nervous i do remember you looking really
nice yeah i remember like i remember
everyone coming in everyone coming in
like sydney just like greeting everyone
everyone's being social and i was like
don't talk to me don't talk to me i'm
making like standing right now i'm
making lasagna connor's like yo go on
can i see your office and i'm just like
no connor i'll show you after i finish
this [ __ ] lasagna
and then and then i'll be social and
then i'll be a good host yeah but until
the design is done nothing has happened
and so
um and so i cooked this on lasagna it's
an hour after sydney had said that the
designer would be finished i don't care
you can't rush perfection and then i and
then i and then i finish it and then i
take it out
and then this is a really weird
experience people start crowding around
this lasagna right it's like oh yeah
people started crowding that around this
lasagna i know you know i'm gonna say it
looks [ __ ] good no it's like i mean i
saw the photos it looks good there's the
thing about lasagna right that you know
anyone who loves lasagna will understand
is it the first
spatula the first serving is always the
best one yeah because the more the more
people start chunking at that lasagna
the more sloppy it becomes yeah don't
get me wrong it's not like lasagna is
the cleanest thing on earth yeah but the
first the first spatula scoop is the
best one yeah so you get the perfect
ratio yeah yeah cause like you know i
needed to make sure like the cheese was
like perfectly toasted because it can't
be like raw cheese and like the edges
need to be like a little bit crispy a
little bit burnt right that's that's to
me that's a good lasagna you can't have
like a completely raw but not too over
burnt lasagna yeah and so i remember i
remember finishing it everyone's taking
a picture i'm like melin
have the first taste
the spotlight comes on silent the room
is silent right i give her the dish
she like she like takes one bite right
and it's just like the longest [ __ ]
few seconds of my life right i see
you're chewing this lasagna and i'm just
like my life is like flashing before my
eyes right now and she's just like
oh [ __ ] you've leveled up and
i can't explain the [ __ ] euphoria
that just went over my body man
it was very good
it was literally that japanese going
i don't remember any of the other food
that was there yeah i remember yeah it
must be good there were sandwiches that
was dangerous
i don't know i don't even i i know there
was a menu but i can't remember anything
else on the menu i mean
what what what what what does it matter
when you have the world famous lasagna i
just i just wanted to be like really
pretentious about it just be like
maybe i hope so but like ever since that
point i'm just like
damn
cooking's fun cooking for other people
can be fun so